Nào tạo thuật mọi một của mày xí là gì?
Nghét à là
Thật thì số này nó là gì số?
Ờ, số gì?
Nguyễn mại mà chơi dở lòng
Hó để đến tại thích chân nhá
Một một một mày xí này nó chỉ là kỳ dọ của đầu tâu thôi
Sống một một một đi, là chỉ cấu hiện chủ mày xe
Một mạnh dẫn đường, một mạnh trước lực và một mạnh thiên sau
Một mày xí này nó là số hiệu dếm của con tầu này
Nó là khi cố chúc bởi vì chủ mày xe
Hãy tụi tụi để để chân mạnh kẹp chạy luôn đó
Ờ, một
Vậy bả, mốn một
Âi chứ một một một tụi
Một mày ngàn, bốn mày ngàn
Sống một mày ngàn, bốn một tụi
Âi thì xin cái bà là dưới xe có thi tòo là một tâm một lên là lắm
Đúng không có ngắm thế luôn
Ê, anh bị khic
Êi nước, hoạt động thế nào vậy
Dù nước để trải cầu rồi
Chính xác, nãy chính là ngôi lý của đàn tầu,
lốt thàn sau đó ngu nước trong lối hơi.
Hơi nước này sẽ tạo ác phúc, ác sức này sẽ lấy tích tông
và tích tông sẽ diễn cho bánh xe quay.
Tạo này có máy cho đi trong lịch sử không ăn,
quan trọng lắm mà nó,
bởi đường sách dịch nha mấy nằm vai cho
cực kì tháng chốt trong thời khẳng sĩnh,
trong việc bận chuyển lưng vực nè,
bú khi và đặc đương bình.
Chính nghề bệnh, tướng sách là một tiêu quán tạc liên tục.
Công nhìn đừng sách là lại tổ thủy đó là những người hùng hùng.
Hãy tòi lấy tòi, bánh gài hưởng nổi,
bánh đêm, nó tối hồng nổi,
chả biết được tất cả như nào.
Sông ra máy mắn chỉ trứng tạo xuân xe đến lưỡi chốn.
Lưng thực nè, bú khi này,
tự kạm thức bình, bình, gửa tức là trên trí tàu ấy tất.
Lưng nó ít đồng dưỡng sách.
Lưng mà, mấy bây giờ,
nó là phá quyết thức ước là hồi nha thột,
đi gà tàu và người luôn.
Lưng mà, đi người,
tìm thột, chúng trước đẹp lấy xin rồi.
Công có vụ khi không còn lúng thực tế,
tế tế cho tình tuyến nhất thì,
có như là chính sĩ thật bạch, hình thật bạch.
Lưng mà, hả nó là mẹ sơ.
Lưng có bác, mốt khi bước lên trên tàu,
nó sẽ tạo xin tử lọng.
Dơ còn đầu tàu hồi nước trải không,
hay là còn bia dân biet tuy.
Thì tạy thì mình đang thay thế bọng đầu mấy dân bà điện truyền
đã hiệu quà hơn.
Nhưng mà, một một một bệnh sĩnh bất phần ăn được bảo tồ như là một thiện bật lịch sử.
Để nhắc nhở chúng ta về một thời gian khi mà kỹ thuật hơi nước làm thay lổi cà thế rối.
Chào mừng đó có cái nào.
Vậy thì các bạn ơi,
thái tháng ngay ai tình này,
nếu như bạch mỗi như tất mắt đầu tổ hơi nước,
đừng hỏi nhá.
Có lúc mình, để xem sơ đi tiếp theo.